маріям булах рифме кулони думала що
ґрунт там ці в нідерландах чужинку
он воно народилося це виросла в
роттердамі
і батько змараг у нього океан солі калію
гуляла місцями їхала автобусом що
завжди зав'язувалася аякасі розмова all
це пір'я та ноги вишиваю я kno мене за
судом дивуватися не міг думаєте що ти
тут рубіж ти не маєш ніби тут можемо
нитки воїни скажуть all і так я
підшиваються до тестової фанфари ви на
навчання герт вілдерс лідер права папулей
ську партії свободи
він прах на пункті на виборах щось врахував
це шкода його перед вибір чия компанія
суть на андрей ісламська пропаганда
вин купа зуби на це перейти до мусульман
закриті мучите таза буруни ти коран
mission і покотив і багато марокканських
пакетики у нідерландах та hero blyad але
ще ви латина безтурботним їзди бич їхнього батька
молоді люди я heaven виграли вибори
нідерландів завантажую ризики і управу і
c у мультикультурній околиці того, хто надав
тулилася а душа толерантну ура працями
половина населення мігранти ще бути схожим
easy star 7 10 краєм з рідних фарид
вінчали ти ну і приїхала з бути com з
мароко
сьогодні вчили against зріс горілку місця
та old ways
ми стали теми відкриттів до світла
алсу вілдерс хоче закриті кордони the
hips а ось і менше нідерланди якобсон
знову ім'я відчувають туди не для сау і
квн прима ж на виборах так рівним
україну та турботи лякати для економіки
проведення русла закінчується і сенат з над good
food of africa ну млинець адреса анди
європейські курсі вілдерса прийду
пантелича молодих заповзятливий багата
знак же розмір кіготь для них це поза
матч і ну а джабез ​​європейського видного
ринку
підприємствам пов'язані руки вбивши юрій
якунін орландо виведуть із європейського
союзу буду складні шизоїд і капітал
вийти на міжнародних партнерів
клієнту що для нас весна вкрай важлива
портом
я до і виберу для своєї україни чіпати
нідерландська встановить удома вже 15
березня
сьогодні тут відбудуться парламентські вибори